>>Maria: Eighty percent of
our kids come on a school bus.
Average I guess travel
time one way is 40 minutes.
So they have to have that commitment
to say, "Yeah, I'm going to be
at the bus stop at six
o'clock in the morning."
>>Narrator: Students are drawn
from all over Los Angeles
to Bravo Medical Magnet High School.
Named after an East Los Angeles
physician, Bravo is a medicine
and health career themed school.
>>Joe: So that will help
to protect her ears.
>>Narrator: The curriculum
exposes every student to aspects
of the medical field and
offers more focused studies
in small academies within the school.
Bravo also offers outstanding
dance and music programs.
>>Teacher: One, two,
three, four, five, six--
>>Narrator: Clubs and athletics.
>>Teacher: Paso numero uno.
>>Narrator: Parental support groups.
And partnerships with
local institutions
like the USC Medical Center.
>>Joe: So when do the
nerves stimulate?
Do they stimulate at the same time
that the hormone does, or not?
>>Maria: We are probably about 85
percent free and reduced lunch.
So our kids are not
middle class kids.
But I believe that when you have
high expectations and you have
that support system that will help
students that are having difficulty,
when you believe in them and they
feel that you believe in them,
they will do anything
you ask of them.
>>Dea: So this electrode is going
to be measuring your brainwaves.
So I'm going to put one
electrode on your forehead,
and one electrode on your ear.
>>Joe: A major focus of the class is
to have the students become curious
that they raise their own questions
that are focused around physiology.
>>Dea: I came up with a
hypothesis that people
who play video games more might
actually have a lower stress level
than people who didn't.
So I started asking people, "Do you
consider yourself a gamer or not?"
And then I would test them.
>>Joe: And then also having
the technology to be able
to measure biopotentials or
blood pressure or vital signs.
>>Joe: Exercise can
actually reduce stress.
>>Dea: Right.
>>Joe: How could that work?
>>Dea: That's something I still
want to test, because I still think
that athletes will have
a lower stress level,
just because they have an
output for that stress.
>>Narrator: Some Bravo students
continue their education
in the afternoon by walking three
blocks from the high school to one
of the most prestigious
medical centers in the country.
>>Maria: We have a
terrific partnership
with the University of
Southern California.
With the ROP program, the students
work at the hospitals that are owned
by USC in a variety
of different areas.
>>Student: And where
is she going today?
>>Maria: We know that not every
student that comes here is going
to be a doctor, going
to go to medical school.
But it helps them see that it's
not just the doctors that make
that whole health medical
world happen.
>>Narrator: A select group of
students in Bravo's science,
technology, and research program, and
the Engineering for Health Academy,
work in research labs on
the USC medical campus.
>>Nouri: These experiments
are really very high-level,
sophisticated experiments.
Just the same experiments
that the post docs
and graduate students are doing.
So the high school students are
really-- this is fantastic for them.
They can do very cool stuff.
>>Hey Harvey.
>>Student: Hey.
>>What are you working on?
>>Student: Right now,
I'm just trying to smooth
out the output of this circuit.
>>Mark: We actually have curricula
that we've instituted
towards biomedical engineering
and engineering in life
sciences which goes hand in glove
with the experimental
experience in the lab.
Education has to be
much more hands on.
We can't continue to just
educate students in silos
and not integrate technologies in
this case into medical applications.
>>Teacher: The way that the course is
designed, it's a two period, right?
>>Student: Mm-hm.
>>Teacher: And the first semester,
you learn medical terminology.
>>Narrator: Many students
entering Bravo are classified
as at-risk academically.
So the school offers a
range of support services
for students and their parents.
>>Maria: Twice a month, the
parents meet with the counselors.
The counselors provide workshops
for them, and then they sit
with their child and they teach
them how to read their report card,
how to call the teacher, how to
have a parent-teacher conference.
So really helping parents
and kids better communicate.
And helping the parents to know which
questions they should be asking.
>>Narrator: There are also homework
help programs monitored by some
of the many Bravo alumni
who return to the school
to help the next wave of students.
>>Rolando: I do want to see
a lot of these kids succeed.
And I can see, you know, why
some of the teachers try so hard
with many of the students.
The more you know them, the
more you really want them
to grow for themselves.
>>Rolando: In this one, what
do you think we're looking for?
>>Student: N.
>>Rolando: N, all right.
>>Marsela: Definitely
Bravo gave me so much.
It got me really prepared for
college, and I didn't think
that back when I was here.
I was like, "Oh my God,
I have to read how much?
I have to do this?
I have to write this essay?"
Then when I got to college, I'm
like, the first couple of classes,
like, "Oh, this is a breeze."
You know, I read-- like, yeah,
I read this in high school.
And I really wanted to come back
and give some of that to the kids.
>>Maria: Don't let anyone,
especially yourself,
say this is something I can't do.
>>Maria: I'm not a person
that supports the status quo,
because usually status quo means it's
about the adults and
not about the kids.
And when it's about kids,
you see the results.
It's not easy, sometimes.
But it's the work that we have to do.
>>Maria: All right,
guys, have a great day.
>>Student: Thank you.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to edutopia.org.